this is a production of Cornell
University for the experience sorry for
my big accent French accent so second
conference English so I will do my best
so for me I will share you the first my
story okay so our my I create my my
vision my own experience that's maybe
help you where I'm going okay
so this is my the future I
imagine if the
relationship with Earth fer relationship
relationship
with
with fing is the I value that farmer can
have for me that's a future I I have
okay that's the the quality of the
relationship of the Earth the way we
form that's the value I have
vision and on my journey I'm always
explorating for I'm curious guy really
curious and and my first journey about
what start my
University double s house J hard
understand s
to build Sal this my why is always the
to understand Sal and so much
important and my f is on inclc MAR is
125 Acres I'm a guy start run zero he's
a farmer is a family farm of my uh
exwife okay we start a business together
is well organic since 35 years okay
since last year I would explain that so
it is a entrepreneur Journey okay wear
we learn make make
mistakes and we
build first business and me
processing we we we bu R zero to have 25
55 15 employers to direct sale marketing
meets okay project I did with my ex-wife
okay and I understand if when you're a
farmer you are always issues and about
economic
rentability agronomic issues and process
transformation coning issu in process
and marketing process and we need to be
really L on three of them okay each form
have different strategy okay but I
understand the value of this okay so
that's for me that's really important
okay and to be entrepreneur to
understand this okay and in
2016 okay I decid to divorce
okay to be couple business really high
challenge okay I told the farm I sell
the business transformation part to My
exwife take the farm okay and a big
challenge for
me and I have a
big because you know be farmer it's
a big Club
you know
cash and I myself of what is my
readership what I give what I take from
learn my journey so also the durity
about King okay my my technical values
also questioning this moment of
vulnerability so organic system you know
because when you become and really
vulnerable you become
like statue really
mobile so that's for
me one of my biggest moment in my life
because I transform myself to see things
differently okay and I C all the verion
practices principle you know because you
know when you a farmer how you create
value life Sons water horns you have no
power on that only power on what might
my relationship with the heart and what
I can
see and also what I need to respond to
cure
so and for me the first thing orig
foring is empathy first thing empathy
with yourself empathy with your other
empathy with your life principle of life
and we need to minimize
disturbance put diversity keep covers
Mak living a
rooms LIF I I tell you also my form I
have 1,000 Pig for finishing process and
Sol
manual so
um for me so to implement process is to
complexity
of so usually we
are said the empty war
parad and only one same space time and
when we do regenerative practice we need
to combine put some in the same time
it's more complex to manage two
different three different four 10
different divers still in the same space
but we need to understand because for me
we need to
manage all this the flow of Life
difference transformation okay of flow
of life of the diversity and Tra design
or management in SpaceTime
okay and on my question okay on my
journey of questioning I met Greek
monitors my
last
year but for me this guy is really
dedicated to the soul heal Journey so 15
years Nots and that guy teach me
that moment it
wasan only one once and three years only
for two three units of n nrens of corn
yeah
maybe 40
times high so I'm really curious what
this guy
do and this this guy Lead Me by Example
very important to when you farmer to
have example to have give your trust
okay that's really important and also I
I came to see
Other M of orative practice
in US mostly okay and when I listen the
story of them
okay understand the key is the crop
diversity and space okay this is a
river and when I
noce
each the most ADV reg farmer we have
less lesson books
lessers they have around 25 different
species and seven years space
example seven seven
is 18 is
C and more you have diversity you sure
you manage those diversity more your
system is on
balance and I understand that and also
on my joury ending I I have a lot of
pressure issues with
water I no one all the
weeds I have in the Cobra I don't with a
family
speci so the weeds for me is unconscious
diversity that go there
[Music]
because supp the needs of the S need
here so we need to turn on this table to
put this diversity on your system okay
and I can go there more deeply on this
this side but for me that's
really interesting okay
so down on on the top warm season cold
season
you
[Music]
have and example we
need G the game p of diversity dash
cover example if you have a corn like a
dash it's prefer to
put before you pass to
transformation if we respect this you
have more chance to and to have more
balance with low low system
get I this is we need to understand more
deep that's this
some and when I listen some former story
of Cl
diversity I have this map of reference
behind this is 80%
works we need to be more on this give I
want so and when I understand I need to
put prop diversity on my system okay I
decide to all I can do it and I have
idea to do cor 60 in okay to put
80% and put 80% of space but 20% less
but I put diversity and I
haveh but I give space time
this good balance for me that's
represent what farming
is the L in really short
time really symmetric way so we
experiment and one thing I understand
also so it's impossible to Discovery a
version of practice design validated
alone because we have only one
interation year to to to experiment you
need some
Farmers Open Mind farmers and every time
we try to try to experiment because each
farmer have own perspective own
experience so we need to to and I use
the think in to
start have good methodology experiment
to design thinking is really is really
interesting I work
also experiment HD ONN so and I I use
also small equipment
thiser from really small we valid more
this work
more you need to understand to validate
something because sometime we need
equipment to get the Rhythm done so
that's one thing we did okay and on my
journey okay I understand at this moment
we take to
validate Regin this practice design we
need around five to 10
years but I entrepreneur I need to
be rentability so what I can grow is
really I have no less risk I have no
time to to validate my cash
example I decide to F
SE why because F SE p on H on R is that
for me the longterm story of validating
in North am this receipt works okay and
I try to u to uh to to implement this
okay
and my entrepreneur joury when I sell
Meats she sell some nuts and my side on
the market Mar and I sell some sausages
but 15 years after that she had a big
business to 35 million sales nor market
and I was was good idea so I I see her
have a good idea to go see
so okay I will try I will buy your seat
so it give me the trust okay to go there
and experiment okay so and what we
techical
is
after and one the biggest asset of this
but
example it's around 66% less RIS less
of2
nrog so because the is more
dry
lission that's for me
impct and you
capture for impct of this Technical and
since four year okay I work
with I move my business model works on
different Farmers where I implement the
produ not on my pH my phone where I work
other farmer to validate the risk
validate the risk and really inov and we
TR
in organic black so we work
in Soul we work in we use trip we use
different fizer
and we
try try validate recipe help farmer to
impl this recipe
well and learn about
that and and three years that's my
combine need to the B
so equipment I bought
from so I learn all the
processing wash D in okay but in in
three
years we get the the
market snack the first produce in snack
market and the it was for me a
big good sucessful story of entrepreneur
okay and the first year of this year we
we get done no tail organic were really
L see but the last second
year was
NE so we we you see we use we try to
strip we we combine together because we
have issu no sometimes the is not
but when what we we at the beginning
without is the best of two
walls reason is
impossible because when we
strip it's
jungle and we need equipment like
finger manage the space and you have
also
this
manage
of and it's really more expensive and so
so at this moment for me it was too much
enough for me so I decided to system so
this perfect and some softness in my
life okay
make so I so I decide so I I and we move
for the first produ to be
origin
so if I I
don't create
value I don't I can't share this value
with I need to need to try pay me for
know for my process you know and example
organic system price I need to
charge is do but at
$699 package that's a pretty price can
pay enough we can't go so
tellers we are really short really less
NR really less education every side we
are really with nature with S health is
really good so we we create value and
after we can share this so and right now
the
challenge is to give trust to the
consumer all orig make sense for the
future that's the challenge I have right
now okay and the idea we have it's you
know create Board of
Matrix each
imp because for me to
be farmer is like driv
know when your seeds like when you
taking up taking off you
know no chance you know
and for each matrix
it's we need
tostem okay and that's and this
dashboard will need some help F to
implement practice but also we need
Matrix to tell the tar the
costume that's really important
things
and for also we can need to show where
is the value of
fing and this year this
year really this summer we have really
tough here we have a really drought
really Dr
when
I
watch and
after
really but this year on two fi on seven
two Fields I double the
[Music]
of
what's
the one f is 10
years one four years so that's really
more resilient and why because when so
water go through and andology
they can they feed the nitrogen and a
good timing for
two system not enough so this
year and for me one of the biggest value
to practice is that the value of the
problem we
don't more
resilience so and right now this is my
entrepreneur journey of this
project it's an exploration project
where
usually
this I talk
about after that but this when you start
a project like
practices explor to learn Lear Lear
right now I'm really close to to scale
the project I'm really good to form need
to
validate and for me
the the future and big issues of reg
practices is a
m retive practice for me is a dash crop
cover crop and
S not
[Music]
only and we need to validate what I give
and take in symmetry the
in space time and we need have matri to
validate this make some
storying
about or creade value
of the is
and
cor and if we for me the biggest value
is the
design and way see the SE design for me
is the way
to measure
because if I see only the design it's
possible to Val the value of
so for me biggest value is the design so
need go around
this
and one of the biggest
issues when we
move
we
and for me is
arure design support
EV focus on what
we compare Oran system we remove for
practice more focus on
what that's
for if we need more be more one more one
we need to remove
something not the same
leadership so and the design we need to
create Li we use intence nature
process we need to design limit problem
possible we we focus more on the real
result
as
system processing
[Music]
for
me and once we gain change we are the
same and one thing is is really hard to
understand so when we we go on have Jo
if you compare to the
system
you around 20%
less you need to get the is
not car energy need some time also so
and if you compare only the basine
of you always 20% l
and all we can give the trust the farmer
you will L 20% on short term you trust s
out in for five years the
dividend will
become happens it happens on what less
information more fertility less problem
we will
have so and right now we have less
example that that's one issues we have
and we need to migrate this value
migration value of
20% an
insurance so and and see some
different
stage covering solution you have this
but it's not magical it's on time we
need to find a way to keep TR
the farmer to
that so this is the book really
interesting that's
my value how to design The
Matrix we change the leadership of we
need change
measure and one thing is we did also
this year one thing I trust is the
knowledge experience of
F and we we grow
we make S gaming
experience 100 farmers
withous put together on table we put
some on tractor and stuff
and everything is possible designed
together the system
but put
knowled and this is I trust the system
because each Farmer at home
exp and together we can challenge
together and also my vision if
digitalize the processing of
forming and create a digital Community
to doing
this the forming will we will move
forward
because far farming is a farmer give
trust World
Farmers so I really example so when I
listen some scientific stuff example in
February really impress at the
moment assist of
representation but the real when on the
M tractor Tri the water will come
tomorrow the bank account is as empty as
up at this moment you don't you f up
the but
you remind your for friend
started so that's the reason we need
some farmer Community to bring forward
and help farmers to implement and give
metrix to
to this is a little
tricky slide okay for me a beginning
question what is the evolution
processing very
design
usually we this this is exploration
processing the way we create
Design This is the way
implement
but in to be really good and more
fast we need failure processing
system and usually example people don't
like to
fail but if you need to validate how
much important is dashboard each point
important you need because if you fail
hard this something you need to be adven
important that teach you that and you
need to
exploration
[Music]
different
each that's important that's the for
process and we need this for approach
trial small
of the
Box
valid
soas
cover
processs what equipment I use
different
and if I have cover and cash
ra
Design This is I can go
moreb andu more
deep is the way we create
new so and we need to validate if the
solution is increased if the gas
emission is reduced if we have water
resilience that's one thing basic stuff
we
valate and at the beginning we are more
andge more ADV because this for me is
minimum years processing this is
around timeline of processing
[Music]
and need to validate the of each design
and what
understand why and works for is the
synchronous of Caron FL
[Music]
the
timing
Val and also each
design we can
manage
the more you you you aware on
M more we can validate you know on the
F so with our instit
payment we get the yield
done so and also that kind of Stu can
help different Insurance that's ins map
we can help own to Insurance system for
me the farmer will get so
help in the future we have less issues
for me the payment for insurance was
less than guys don't think
about it's like guys make more made the
recommendation for
insurance so and also that the dashboard
can create some
different
Matrix value of assets I think for the
consumer the Nutri score really
important so PLS humit and to get the
value for the customer
for
[Music]
score and and which set design what's
possible with AI and data
validate because we need to create
assets for the people who buy
because that's
the the issues is really hard to to
people want pay more for something don't
see to create value for
people so that's is for me orig
practices and one thing for me
with digitalization of
farming it would be impossible to
digitalize all
the we need to
digitalize design
reference design we can measure the
difference
by this the reference at the beginning
we need to use
[Music]
dat
Matrix because we need to reference the
Des that's
job and when we Implement more have less
less Precision
what
reference so that's really fast it was
really hard to explain the vision of
this really fast but I will you some
question very much I think we have time
for question so
okay okay yes it thank you very much for
for sharing time with us and I love your
your presentation I was wondering um
whether you had maybe some sound bites
or some some uh examples of where
interactions between what you do and the
academy University researchers has
worked for you and also where you think
in the future you have a need that has
not been met that you think could be
covered Yeah by academic research that's
my one I need more collaboration right
now because right now the mo
iide
my get less pressure my system get
more
experiment
and
so don't understand all theion I have so
but I need
more
[Music]
collaboration really
hard the
[Music]
f
something
but
open oh so so you're saying maybe
monitoring of
quantifying the results
right
[Music]
experiment
sense so for
mey project is small
project but really
agile because really
[Music]
and also I start project
with
get and Tra Jour of this and if we
understand each step corly after that
[Music]
great great presentation my question to
you was you talked about this timeline
three years 15 years I mean you know
obviously think of that I mean it's
tough for some of these Growers to be on
that time timeline to fail and so forth
how do you encourage them to get on the
kind of the bandwagon and and kind
of this is it easy or you
[Music]
have
more
you
SC need to be really clever on the scale
because
my is to scale too
fast design
on and we need to have a energy to
things so for me the I
have 10 forms
one each
and some experiment and farmer follow
some some from small and after that we
thinking system after that we make
one after one year we go together
offer what activity on the farm is
currently your
biggest so the the big right now is my
security but my trap right now I I
th every and ride for
SE good
cash I witer
canol
Buton and for the pumpkin seats how
important was it that collaberation with
somebody who can sell them at a high
price
I
first
customer
Master customer for this project did it
make a difference for you so much so
much because this woman give me the
trust to go
[Music]
deep
have a woman give you a trust you will
sell your prod that's so
much and is it more the trust versus the
price like which
one the price the price is a the price
is
that um this opportunity because I sell
the same price being B the from
austalia but the value I give to her we
made
it so that's the value value and for
Value because for the marketing
position so that's the value I get and I
know this value and I take
this when I sell the price same
price
and and when I negotiate the price when
I Mo
[Music]
reg
but organic so
I can
[Music]
that for
breathing for me genetics is a really
high value that's really
important we need genetics for we need
example my
16in genetics of that's made so much
difference so much we need genetic is
fit in
cash and cover too and sometimes we
don't
cover
simp so
[Music]
much dooming five days more ear five
days more ear that's
change because it's possible
[Music]
to there's a question
online what could be the timeline to
apply regenerative a in sendy soils
versus L soils we have
[Music]
that
precisely but it's not the same issues
some sem
Mor issue but water
issues I think for we need to that's
reason we need to map mapping the
journey
7 need of each Soul home Evolution
journey and we need to Val to measure
that more deep to understand more what
is
each
step and also tricky part
[Music]
isers so that's we need to know learn
more
more so we need to understand more thanp
so what's
the with good F cover
[Music]
need
for yeah especially great presentation I
really appreciate it I like your
comments about failing so we do a lot of
failing in in my lab and fail the fail
fast model is yeah I think
underappreciated so um but I had a
question about your digitalization of of
Agriculture and the dashboard can you
say more about what you would be
measuring and what's going to help you
with management yeah
J the
picture so that's
my this is my uh my dashboard for this
project so here we have and the
DAT
Fall
City after that so what the percent of C
what the first FL what
the how
many and after
spread first SCH cover out okay after
that what the
winter
percentage
pass what is the
after what's
the homogeneity
fi what's the state of
rment what's the bass
before what's the
state of R When We R
[Music]
that's because
that's and the carbon flow is one of the
biggest nutrients we need to know the
carbon flow the
reconst time
11 you one a
big you can
of
a that's and for the
pamp the mar knew the quantity of
pin and Sal out fertility you knew the
size of
p and
both
with and
after
that's here is the timeline and after
that what's
the
percentage all the carbon flow on
the all
H and after
that fungus
bacteria have more what
[Music]
the common analis and also I I don't
this but I have
other that b only
for
seeds the ratio of form and
male fun the ratio fun male
stress fun if
more
that
that's so each
crop I have a
home and then how do you use this
information to change your
management so if you're if you have
table that's coming in in these
different areas
example I
really watch I know
I have good
enough I
need that's can
manage to implement and with the
strategy that's really important that's
because it's always changing we want
when we start we
start so we need
to
so
that's we need to understand each
Matrix
[Music]
not yeah so and I
notic more the soul heal is good
the ferz the fation
most from natural way
problem
I the is
more more defensive
mechanism so we need more go deep
understand so and we know some different
stage
each is a red yellow and
red you
know you're in
red and
for I
[Music]
remove and the the value we creat we put
clever way on
forming works and we don't use chemical
for
f but we have we have make the pro of
concept we have done to prevent the
problem bound with
for and started getting to us for the
this has been a production of Corel
University on the web at cornell.edu